so
efficient and hushed are our brains in
their day-to-day operations
we are apt to miss what an extraordinary
and complicated achievement
it is to feel mentally well a mind in a
healthy state
is in the background continually
performing
a near-miraculous set of maneuvers that
underpin our moods of clear-sightedness
and purpose to appreciate what mental
health might be
and therefore what its opposite involves
we might take a moment
to consider some of what will be going
on in the folds of an optimally
functioning mind
first and foremost a healthy mind is an
editing mind
an organ that manages to sieve from
thousands of stray dramatic
disconcerting or horrifying thoughts
those particular ideas and sensations
that actively need to be entertained in
order for us to direct our lives
effectively
partly this means keeping at bay
punitive and critical judgments
that might want to tell us repeatedly
how disgraceful and appalling we are
long after harshness has ceased to serve
any useful purpose
when we are interviewing for a new job
or taking someone on a date
a healthy mind doesn't force us to
listen to inner voices
that insist on our unworthiness it
allows us to talk to ourselves
as we would to a friend at the same time
a healthy mind resists the pull of
unfair comparisons
it doesn't constantly allow the
achievements and successes of others to
throw us off course
and reduce us to a state of bitter
inadequacy
it doesn't torture us by continually
comparing our condition to that of
people who have
in reality had very different
upbringings and trajectories through
life
a well-functioning mind recognizes the
futility and cruelty
of constantly finding fault with its own
nature
along the way a healthy mind keeps a
judicious grip on the faucet of fear
it knows that in theory there is an
endless number of things that we could
worry about
a blood vessel might fail a scandal
might erupt the plane's engines could
shear from their wings
but it has a good sense of the
distinction between what could
conceivably happen
and what is in fact likely to happen and
it is able to leave us in peace
as regards the wilder eventualities of
fate
confident that awful things will either
not unfold
or could be dealt with ably enough if
ever they did so
a healthy mind avoids catastrophic
imaginings
it knows that there are broad and stable
stone steps
not a steep and slippery incline between
itself
and disaster a healthy mind has
compartments with heavy doors
that shut securely it can
compartmentalize where it needs to
not all thoughts belong at all moments
while talking to a grandmother
the mind prevents the emergence of
images of last night's erotic fantasies
while looking after a child it can
repress its more cynical
and misanthropic insights aberrant
thoughts about jumping on a train line
or harming oneself with a sharp knife
can remain brief
peculiar flashes rather than repetitive
fixations
a healthy mind has mastered the
techniques of censorship
a healthy mind can quieten its own
buzzing preoccupations
in order at times to focus on the world
beyond itself
it can be present and engaged with what
and who is immediately around
not everything it could feel has to be
felt at every moment
it can be a good listener a healthy mind
combines an appropriate suspicion of
certain people
with a fundamental trust in humanity
it can take an intelligent risk with a
stranger it doesn't extrapolate from
life's worst moments
in order to destroy the possibility of
anything good emerging with a new
acquaintance
a healthy mind knows how to hope
it identifies and then hangs on
tenaciously
to a few reasons to keep going grounds
for despair
anger and sadness are of course all
around
but the healthy mind knows how to
bracket negativity
in the name of endurance it clings to
evidence of what is still beautiful and
kind
it remembers to appreciate it can
despite everything
still look forward to a hot bath some
dried fruit
or dark chocolate a chat with a friend
or a satisfying day of work
it refuses to let itself be silenced by
all the many
sensible arguments in favor of rage and
despondency
outlining some of the features of a
healthy mind helps us to identify what
can go awry
when we fall ill we should acknowledge
the extent to which mental illness is
ultimately as common
and as essentially unshameful as its
bodily counterpart
true mental health involves a frank
acceptance
of how much ill health there will have
to be in even the most ostensibly
competent
and meaningful life and we should be no
more reluctant to seek help
than we are when we develop a chest
infection or a sore knee
and should consider ourselves no less
worthy
of love and sympathy
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected
areas of life click now to learn more
you